Comstock Brewing asks Gary if you were
gonna crush it by starting a brewery
what would you do
Comstock great question uh you know
obviously I've thought a lot about this
because I always do think about
producing products and selling them I
come from a retail background a lot of
our clients or cpgs consumer packaged
goods products that sell to consumers
and I always say what if I had one and
obviously beer coming from the world I
grew up in in fact when I first got into
my dad's business that was the real
first boom of microbrews back in like
nineteen nineties five-six-seven-eight
it was a huge boom back then and thought
a lot about that um look I mean I think
the thing that's going on is a couple
different things first of all I'd win
locally I think microbrews really need
to focus locally so I would probably go
to every local business within a
five-mile radius by hand and shake hands
and kiss babies to create relationships
so that they use you know like there's a
there's a insurance company that's 147
employees down the street in Cincinnati
and you go there and you become friends
and they use your beer for their events
right so I think localization really
matters the next thing I would really
focus on would be probably Instagram I
would go all in on creating a very
serious profile on Instagram and then
using Facebook dark posts ads to drive
links from the Facebook ad to your
Instagram to get people following there
because I think the 21 to 30 year old
demo is living and breathing in that
platform and I think it matters for you
to win in that platform number three I
would really focus on getting two to
three states to carry my beer and then
build very strong relationship with a
sales team of that small distributor
because you're small microbrew you're
probably gonna be with a small
distributor you don't get lost in a big
one what I mean by that is the people
that represent you know Budweiser and
Sam Adams and things of that nature
you're a little 500 cases a year gets
lost somewhere in the back of the
warehouse nobody cares so you want to go
somewhere small where you're you know a
bigger fish in that smaller pond I think
you picked two or three strategic
markets and then I would run Facebook
dark posts ads and Twitter local ads in
that market to build up some hype so now
listen I'm gonna go your stuff sells so
those are some of the tactics I would do